Alex here with the game spot news update
cliff bleszinski that really cool guy
game designer who worked on Unreal
Tournament in Gears of War is back after
a two year long retirement with a new
project after a few days of teasing on
Twitter including the use of a countdown
timer Laszewski has revealed that his
new project will be codenamed blue
streak not much is known about the game
except it is a free-to-play sci fi arena
shooter for the PC which sounds like a
return to the Unreal Tournament style of
game that make with a thief famous the
game is being developed by blue since
keys new studio bosque productions with
South Korean company nexon best known
outside of Asia for free to play games
like maplestory Laszewski left at the
games two years ago after 20 years of
the company he helps create the Unreal
Tournament series and was the lead
designer on Gears of War epic now
without blues NP recently announced that
they will be making a new unreal
tournament which will also be free for
now details about blue streak are scarce
but luzinski did say here the answering
questions tomorrow so keep it locked to
gamespot for future updates